you look so comfy that's like the
perfect size bed for you so we just got
to Orlando we just got our hotel room
this is what's happening in front of me
that's why I'm like whoa nice view of
the parking lot Beauty it's cute look at
this it's like a whole apartment yes you
like it with me yeah okay so we're in
Orlando tomorrow we're gonna be checking
out the Daytona 500 with NASCAR so swats
brought us out here so we just woke up
we woke up like at 6 a.m. today we've
been on a plane all day and now East
Coast time at 7 p.m.
I'm just waiting yeah we haven't really
had a day we're gonna go visit your
cousin oh yeah tomorrow after NASCAR we
get to go see my cousin Jenny and my two
nephews and her husband Joe I'm so
excited to see them because the baby the
last time we were here he was literally
a newborn like like this like tiny
shaking I know I know he's like - oh my
gosh it's been that long since we've
oh my god yeah I'm so excited to see
Jenny I cannot wait us after the NASCAR
stuff which I'm also excited for yeah
yeah we're bringing you guys with them
this has been awesome because I'm not
doing anything for this trip I let Casey
handle it because swab brought Casey out
he's the one that got us the uber to get
to the hotel and I told you I'm like do
not look at me I don't know anything
this is your trip because I got spoiled
from the last time I traveled which was
to Bora Bora by myself so I'm like
listen you can handle it you big boy I
know that's why I'm like I'm like I have
faith in you you got this it's just that
every single trip that we've ever taken
I'm the one leading the way and I'm like
letting go of the reins now so you've
got this so now we're about to head over
to dinner and go meet the team that
brought us out here so that's next and I
don't have to worry about a single thing
I just get to chill
yeah well he figures it out I love this
I like it when you do that it's cute I
don't know I just like it
I missed the cheese board that she's so
graceful cheese for
Mexican pizza house is good
[Music]
you know more
[Music]
[Music]
accidentally started cutting into
someone else which a lot of it has a
piece of that enchilada in Iran report
and you're gonna eat it
waitresses than that look to that big
boy you got it nice have you ever pulled
under these out before that was your
first time pulling out a mattress out of
a couch nice is it comfy I think it
looks so comfy that's like the perfect
sized bed for you you ready to go to bed
yeah nice vacation mode on
[Music]
which we just spent all that time making
that bed and he goes into this room goes
I call this bed
[Music]
[Music]
we're ready to go here at Junior
Motorsports I'm excited let's go win
this thing right
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone today is our last
day in Orlando we are packing up and
we're gonna get ready to go see my
cousin Jenny and her family and I'm so
excited because I've been a couple years
since I last seen them you've seen them
in face time true we do see each other
during face time but now we get to see
each other in person I don't get to hug
her a lot do you miss Jenny yeah Wow
Eden is so excited to see you yes
yeah yeah Jenny was like did Isaac come
too because Aiden it would like die to
see him because he's always asking for
you and then now he's a he's a big
brother cool you could ask him what what
that's like that
really yeah he's gonna have to share
like see I get the switch all to myself
I get the love at least I just from this
point on 12 years older than your
sibling is that I have time they're able
to play a switch
I think the switch would be old yeah you
wouldn't even care about it anymore on
to the next new thing that's about to
make of a name name the Xbox 5000 yes
you don't have to worry about sharing
the Xbox to oaken's right now is the one
yeah I think that's the least of your
worries Isaac if anything yeah it's not
not even about sharing for you it's the
noise complaints that's what that's what
you're gonna have to worry about so you
could ask Aiden what that's like
I found your Lucky Penny it's even
luckier oh it was head side up side up
nice it is the most watery Khan what
that looks like tea yeah why does it do
that
did you put too much water I mean I mean
a whole pie yeah but maybe for the
amount of coffee that they give you it's
supposed to be like one cup doing so did
you read the instruction no of course
not remove filter pack from packaging
lately filter completely flat on the
bottom of the brew basket upon
completion of the route yeah it doesn't
oh this pot bruised four cups how many
cups of water did you put
- you put six cups of water no wonder
that's why it's watery can I pour this
back in and brew more talking you think
all wrong maybe five tosses out and do
another one well you should have read
the instructions so we had pizza last
night and some wings and this pizza the
reason why I ordered a was because it
said it was New York style pizza we were
like oh we're on the East Coast maybe
it'll be close to New York style it was
a complete and utter fail because the
cheese was gross it looked like a New
York style pizza but it did not taste
like one at all
the wings however were quite delicious
and I could just see the bones so
pecking now they're gonna leave and
figure out what to do about breakfast
because by the time we went downstairs
to get breakfast it was already 20
minutes past the time they stopped
serving it a side note I broke a nail so
this is very annoying all weekend I've
been trying to hide it every time we
take photos I'm like well yeah okay
right look at me look at my babies no
that's all you're so big
[Music]